according to caviesel accepting the
title role in The Passion of the Christ
all but ensured the death of his
Hollywood career in fact only minutes
after Mel Gibson offered him the role of
biblical proportions the director tried
to talk him out of it as cavizel told
one church congregation he said you'll
never work in this town again I told him
we all have to embrace our crosses but
cavizel claimed to care little for
Hollywood Awards accolades or the Walk
of Fame and was willing to sacrifice his
career for an opportunity in Gibson's
interpretation of the story of Jesus
explaining Jesus is as controversial now
as he's ever been not much has changed
in 2000 years we have to give up our
names our reputations Our Lives to speak
the truth